all right so um I'm Joe Dolin er i'm
here from rethink TB today and i'm going
to talk to you about the product that
we're making there and we've been
working on for i guess the last three
and a half years now which is about how
long I've been there um so rethink to be
sort of the one line slug of what it is
is it's an open source distributed data
store for unstructured data now that may
seem to some people like sort of a
trouble of those words but basically it
is is it's a database it's distributed
so you can install it on a whole cluster
of machines and paralyze data access
across them you could increase the total
amount of storage like that and it's for
unstruck meaning that unlike with sequel
you don't have to decide ahead of time
how exactly you want to structure your
data you can just throw that into it so
um what are my goals are this for this
talk are i'm going to go over a few
things first um the cap theorem which is
something that always comes up in the
discussion of databases arm and sort of
can't get around it because it really
winds up affecting what it's like to use
the database um the second which is I
think a little bit more interesting is a
functional approach to a query language
so we have our own custom-made query
language called r equal and it's very
functional in its nature it it draws
some sort of concepts from the old like
classic functional languages like list
but it tries to be a lot more pragmatic
with those concepts and get you
something that has the benefits but is
also very very good for getting stuff
done um and lastly what I'm hoping to
show with these two things is where I
think rethink TB can sort of fit into
your data science pipeline and like what
sort of a tool it can be in your belt
and so to that end rather than um
showing you a PowerPoint presentation or
something just outlining how we deal
with these challenges um I'm actually
just going to do a little bit of live
coding for you in rethink TB ah right
here and we'll just sort of do some data
analysis and I hope that that sort of
serves as a
forum to answer any questions you might
have about the system so first I've just
getting a feel who here programs
professionally and who here whether or
not they program professionally has a
soft spot for functional languages um
and lastly and this is this question is
you a t-shirt who can tell me what the
cap theorem says or venture a guess yeah
red shirt
mm-hmm yes small medium or large right
so basically the cap theorem it's sort
of like those like pictures you see
online where it's like you know in
college you can have like a social life
of something else pic two um you can't
have it all now one thing that I I want
to uh just state is that the
abbreviations for what consistency
availability and partition tolerance are
are very confusing abbreviations and as
we go into the details will sort of
hammer out exactly what those mean but
so with that in mind up to take you over
to an actual running rethink TB instance
um it's it's running right here on this
macbook which is you know not the
fastest of things so we can't do really
heavy-duty stuff but it's plenty fast
for our purposes and you can see right
here that um I've got this little
website and this is sort of AA ground
zero for any type of database
administration work right this is um
where I go in and I see what what's
going on in my cluster how are my
engineers using it what sort of servers
do I have here and on right here in this
view you can see I have two servers one
named jacaro and one named wisp um which
are which are being run on this machine
right here so this is one view that I'm
going to be using a lot during this and
then the other one is an actual
programming view so you can see here and
just going to scroll that from now well
you can see here we'll see I'm going to
actually start by querying the database
and I'm going to do some simple stuff so
the way that sort of the querying the
database works in rethink TB is you use
a bunch of methods which are defined on
the rethink to be module and right now I
have that imported as our and
these methods I use to construct a query
which is then just a native Python
object and I run it so I'm going to use
a method called expert to construct the
standard introductory on assignment in
any programming course which is hello
world the that's better okay so I call
expert on hello world and what expert
does is it just takes a native Python
object and converts it into something
that the database understands so if i
evaluate this you can see i get a reek
will query instance of the string hello
world and then when i have a query that
i like i can send it over to the server
and see what it thinks of it so I'm
going to take this hello world query and
i'm going to call run on it and so
what's happening here is it gives me
back the string hello world um and what
actually happened there is hello world
got compiled down into a protocol buffer
that gets sent over to the server which
then does some processing on it in the
case of just a simple concept evaluation
it doesn't have to do anything and it
sends it back to me now what's really
cool about this and sort of the whole
reason that you can see sort of the
whole reason that this becomes very
usable is that queries compose using
pythons built-in structures so I'm going
to define another query and this one I'm
going to bind to a variable and this is
the query which evaluates just 21 so now
cool thing about this is suppose I want
to do some basic math I want to do
addition I can take this query object
and I can add it to itself and i get
back another query which zentz the
addition and then when i take this query
and run it again it gets packaged up
into protocol buffers and sent over the
server where it evaluates the addition
and it sends me back the answer which of
course to there should be no surprises
there um but the point and why this
becomes powerful is that queries are in
essence these abstract syntax trees and
native programming languages become the
perfect tools for evaluating these
syntax for creating these syntax trees
and sending them over to the server and
so right now I'm doing it in Python we
have very equivalent drivers in Ruby and
JavaScript and um there's also 12 other
third-party languages that are supported
so any questions with that that concept
of how queries are made first now
everyone's good all right so we can make
queries that's great but of course the
whole point of a database isn't to be
some like programming language that I
evaluate over the wire it's um supposed
to be for storage and so the standard
abstraction we use for storage is tables
which arm if you've done any sort of
data sites i suspect tables are nothing
new to anyone some some people call them
collections or buckets but they're all
basically just this container for your
data so in rethink DB arm I can create a
table call using the table create method
so doing this i'm making a table called
foo and when I evaluate it it's going to
send me back this little summary object
saying I created a table for you um and
then if I want to insert data into it
all that I need to do is call an insert
method
do that it sends me back another summary
object and you can see it has a bunch of
things that it didn't do like deleting
documents but it did insert one document
and then it also has this weird field
here called the generated keys so and
this will be another t-shirt question
who can tell me what a primary key is in
a table exactly small medium or large
there you go yeah um so what he said is
that the primary key is the one that
uniquely identifies something in the
table um and so basically you just
inserted this data into the table but
every we make every piece of data have a
unique identifier it now thing is that
it needs to have a unique identifier but
it would be really annoying if you had
to come up with a unique identifier
every single time so instead if you just
insert something without a unique
identifier we just create one for you
that's just a uuid there that we created
um and so now I've inserted this data
and to get it back is quite pleasant in
Python I can just use the bracket
operator because it's overloaded so when
I do that I get back my one piece of
data now there are a couple of things
that I'd sort of like to point out here
one is that I just inserted a plain
Python [ __ ] I didn't I didn't have to
do anything special to it it's just a
dict and that's really really convenient
if I'm a Python programmer because
chances are any data source I can think
of I know how to get it as Python dates
like I know how to leverage some API
that I find parse the JSON and get the
dicks out and once I know how to do that
then I just need to call insert and now
I've got it in a distributed database
where I'm ready to do some data
processing on it um now the other thing
I'll show you I'm going to take you back
to the web UI here or i can see what
sort of management i can do on this
table so we were just in the servers tab
we have another one here for tables and
here's the table i just created foo now
I just
get some sort of basic information about
the table what's what's going on with it
right now is in right there sharting in
replication which is stuff that will get
to in a little bit and then down here I
can see that exactly which server in the
cluster is being used for this table and
so what happened when i did the table
creation is that it figured out based on
what others were doing which server
would be a good one for hosting this
data based on how many other commitments
had already had and it selected wisp to
be the primary and if I want to if I you
know want to have an extra copy of this
data around all I need to do is have two
replicas instead of one which is just a
kawai here my little red graph that I do
quick little read and now I have two
copies of the data one on wisp and one
on Jack hero and the reasoning to be
uses a primary secondary architecture um
it's also sometimes called a
master-slave architecture so question is
why use a primary secondary architecture
what does having a primary give you from
a cap perspective ah yes founder of
rethink TB exactly and I guess you you
probably want a medium
um so right so it gives you consistency
having having a single node that all the
data goes through guarantees that no two
nodes are ever going to disagree about
the value of the data because the
secondaries just learn from the primary
what's going on um so it depends on
exactly how you configure it the
propagation is not synchronous um and
actually this is fits very nicely with
the view that I have the propagation is
not synchronous if um you don't want it
to be so right now you see how I have
this right here where I'm highlighting
one right acts so that's how many
replicas need to acknowledge the right
before the the right that I did in
Python gets acknowledged to be so right
now it's just one which means that um
just the primary is going to acknowledge
so it could be non-consistent yes the
reason that um it can't be is that if
you really want to do a consistent read
you also route that through the master
um you can if you don't want to because
that's that's an extra hop you can read
in and out of date fashion that's not
guaranteed to be consistent but it's
faster exactly ah any other questions on
this this is this is where it gets sort
of your making those cap trade-offs this
is this is why I've said this a couple
of times that the cap theorem is useful
but if all you know about a database is
is which two letters it picked you
probably don't know the full story
because all of the requirements within
the cap theorem are really really lofty
requirements on that you can sort of
meet halfway a lot of the time and have
it be be useful um okay so I've created
this table I've this and like I said the
real reason that I think that this is
useful in that I like using this API is
I get to use native Python objects and I
know how to get those for anything that
I want and so that's actually exactly
what I did which um and the API used was
wikipedias API
so I assume if you guys are quick you
probably saw when I came in here to the
table food that I've also got this other
table wiki and this is loaded with about
a quarter million articles from
Wikipedia and um I I just loaded these
in using using their API i parse some
json it was probably a 50 line script to
scrape it all it's quite easy and I'm
going to take you back to well so i'm
gonna i'm going to step into actually
the data Explorer here which is a third
tab in our administration and this lets
me actually sorry question in the back
how many megabytes is that um database
that's probably in like hundreds of
megabytes i can tell you for sure in a
second out um but yeah so we're just
doing this on a macbook i actually had a
demonstration set up with like all of
these clustered ec2 nodes but it's sort
of ec2 itself to death and i didn't want
to risk having that happened in the
middle of the talk so we're just doing
it locally on the macbook and so i'm
just going to give you guys a look at
what one of these documents is and here
again i'm going to access the table
except this time it's wiki and i'm going
to do it get now this just uses the
primary key that we were talking about
to retrieve a document and i'm just
going to type in this magic number here
which um i have written down ahead of
time because i happen to know that this
isn't a gigantic document that's going
to fill my screen and then down so as
you can see in this wikipedia or in this
document I've got the content of the
article and I've got it in this kind of
strange form which is that I've taken
rather than having one big string to
represent the content I've tokenized it
into an array and you'll see why I did
that in a second one I do the data
analysis that would be a pretty easy
thing to do live during the data
analysis except that the query would
take a little bit of time and I didn't
want to make everyone wait for that so
I've pre-processed it a bit to get that
working then I've also got the links on
from
this this article two other articles out
of it and if you see a link is
represented as this object that's an NS
which is stands for namespace which i
believe is just the language so 0 just
means english wikipedia and then finally
i've got um some page properties the
page ID which is the primary key and the
title of the document which is the 1985
helsinki protocol on the reduction of
sulfur emissions so I've got these
documents in here and I want to find
something out about them so I'm going to
step out of this into my programming
environment because I'm going to do
something a little bit heavy more heavy
duty so the first thing that think might
be interesting question to ask and why I
chose to tokenize the content is I'm
going to try to count word frequencies
within these documents so I'm going to
take my document that I already had and
the first thing I'm actually going to do
is save myself some typing by putting
that in a variable so now I can just
type wiki yet and I'm going to get out
my variable here I'm going to I'm going
to get out my document here ah the one
on the sulfur emissions and I'm going to
try to figure out all right so how many
times is sulfur mentioned in this
document this will be just a good test
because sulfur should be mentioned at
least once so I select the content field
from it and notice i get i get to just
use my standard Python operators here
and then I call the count method which
is a rethink DB thing but I think
there's an equivalent thing in python
that just lets me count solver end run
that you see what that query looks like
notation of it oh god and when I run
I get back that there's four instances
of the word sulfur in there nothing we
would expect on now it's kind of cool is
that I'm going to want to apply this
function to a lot of documents and so
just like when I'm programming in Python
I can very easily abstract out this
little one line query into a function
and so I'm going to define one right now
which is just a general one called word
count and word count is going to take
two arguments it takes a word and
document and it just returns that value
it returns the document select out the
contents thank you thank you it's like
so that and so now I've got this
function here and it just felt like I
wrote a python function but I can just
as easily use this as a rethink DB
function
it works and so it's actually happening
here is because of how sort of we know
how to compile these functions we're not
actually hacking Python code here I can
or do you do but it knows how to take
this function call it on these objects
to accumulate the abstract syntax tree
and I get to feel like I'm basically
writing on Python code when I actually
get to send this to the database and
have it be all distributed for me so
let's actually please yes exactly so
right so yeah so the quit the question
is we're actually running this code and
um this is sort of like this is the real
crux of of what we're doing in what
makes this query language tick is that
we take these functions and the way it
actually works as we pass in these
little representation objects people and
then you know it does something like a
count method we were now you've got a
variable that you go through you accuse
a black syntax tree and then you sort of
see what comes out the other side and
what comes out the other side is
actually you're quick you just put it in
there and eventually you get the whole
query and you just packaged it up and
send it over and all of these functions
get represented as something the server
understands and to us we sort of saw
this is powerful because we know okay
now we can actually make a pleasant way
to represent a serve of function on the
server and we know that basically once
you've got functions you can do almost
everything you know functions are just
such a powerful thing um particularly
for everyone who said they have a soft
spot for functional languages you know
this like twice as much um you you can
really get so much just out of having
these functions so we do so um let's do
something more interesting with this
function so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to map this function over the
table and so you
I'm sure most people are familiar with
map either from a producer just from
your favorite functional language but
those are what map does is easily it
takes a stream of objects in this case
they're the objects in a table and it
applies the function i give it to every
single element of the stream and gives
me back a stream of objects that are the
applications of that function so in this
case my stream of my objects in the
stream to begin with our Wikipedia
articles and the object they gave me
back is how many times they see a work
and the word that I'm going to look for
is love because I figured that would be
a little bit more evocative than sulfur
and so now this will give me a quarter
million numbers which um well it will
package it up into a sort of lazily
evaluated cursor object but if I wanted
to actually show you the result of this
query um well I need to just scroll a
bunch of output so rather than do that
I'm going to bring in the counterpart to
map which is reduce and what reduced
does is it takes a stream of objects and
a function to combine them it gives me a
way to compact them all up into a single
value so reduce and my reduce function
is just going to be addition so this
query right here will iterate just
through all of the Wikipedia articles
that i have and tell me how many times
it sees the word love and i'm actually
not going to run this as is because it
would take a little bit longer than I
want it to on this mac unfortunately our
performance on max isn't great right now
we only have a 32 bit binary for them so
so we'll run this ah and what we found
is that 2000 is not enough so actually
because one second that will be 2,000
it's
that's going to run for a second and
there's some interesting things about
this query that I want to point out so
the nice thing and all it's already done
and it found 11 copies of the word love
and we can that on a few more and we
were companies but what's really
interesting about this query and why um
I find this very very useful is that
because we have these functions that we
can compile up we know with the
constructions of map and reduce how to
distribute them and that's exactly what
we do so this this query which was
pretty simple you know pythonic style
code to write is actually a massively
distributed query if I put it on a big
cluster if I have 16 machines it can use
all of them right on the box and I don't
need to do anything special to make it
do that um and this is really the whole
reason that you know Hadoop has enjoyed
such popularity and why Google uses
MapReduce so much is that once you can
express stuff in terms of MapReduce you
already know how to scale it um and this
is this is no exception this is exactly
what we get out of MapReduce as well um
so any any questions on how this gets
run yeah yeah sorry so the question is
if it's if it's possible that we could
be a distributed reduce at a time when
it's actually a more beneficial to not
do it distributed reduce for that to be
the case you would somehow have to have
a reduced function which major data
bigger than the entire then the data set
was to begin with um because the only
way basically we distribute the reduce
as much as the data is distributed um
and the main goal of that is to not have
to copy all of the data over the network
it is generally not possible to
Detective a function is going to produce
um a dad data that's bigger than the
data going into it feeling that that
case is quite rare um I mean the main
the main justification for doing the
distributed reduce is avoiding that data
copy but no if there was such a case
then we would be doing it in a
suboptimal way yes yes
so it is it is possible that sorry the
question again yep it's possible that
you could receive an inconsistent result
um if you have multiple replicas and the
answer is that arm you can get
inconsistent result but across documents
so if somebody inserts to documents at a
time it's possible or rather if they
insert document a and then they insert
document be it's possible that depending
on which tables they were inserted to or
which shards they got routed to you
could see document be without seeing
document a um this is kind of a price
you pay in a distributed system because
if you don't want to do that if you want
to have a fully asset system I you have
to pay some pretty significant
performance costs and yeah the real um
particular use case where we've gotten a
lot of people who are actually using
this is in real time analytics because
there you don't really care if like one
user clicked on something and then
another one clicked on it and you see
you zerbies click but not use arrays
click um if you really really need that
that Adam icity and consistency anything
to be is probably not a good choice
because we sacrifice that to get to make
some really useful for real-time stuff
sorry what kind of what Oh what kind of
lag
the replication um well so that we
actually arm you mean in terms of how
long to get to the secondary and be
usable there I mean so in here is that
that's heavily going to be heavily
influence on what your network latency
is armed yeah I unfortunately I mean we
are planning to publish full performance
numbers but I don't really have anything
I'd feel comfortable saying is like a
scientifically measured thing right now
on that yeah uh-huh
ah so this tooth site question is
suppose suppose we inserted a of data it
goes it goes to the master it goes to
one note it goes to a second node but a
third node has some sort of a transient
failure um now of course with these
cases we don't know what the transient
failure is we just know that he didn't
get back to us right and so in that case
it depends on how you've configured your
table if you've configured your table
such that look I don't want to get an
acknowledgement for this until every
single note big too long to respond then
we say this this guy is unavailable.this
the other part of this question is well
now what happens when this node does
come back online um and the answer is
that when a node comes back online and
it is missing a chunk of the data it
will try to get back in contact with the
other people who have that data and
bring itself up to date yep
if it's missing the last 10 minutes of
rights and if it is then it takes it
basically sends okay here's the last
right I saw by um we keep just an
counter on the master and it radios them
and says okay this is the last right I
saw start giving me right since then and
it just gets in a stream of the right
sits we call this a backfill but it
basically just fills it in on everything
that it missed okay so where we were in
the talk we've compiled this data we've
um we've compiled these functions we've
sent them over and I've counted the
number of occurrences of a word so
that's fine but to do data analysis I
want to do something a little bit more
interesting which is that um rather I
want to look at the percentage of the
words in an article which are a certain
word and that's going to be a little bit
closer to telling me what the article
might actually be about so I'm going to
define a slightly more complicated
function than my previous one called
word percent and like word count that
just takes a word in a document and well
we all know how to compute a percent the
first thing who is compute the numerator
and now what's kind of nice about this
is since these are Python functions
there's absolutely nothing to say that I
can't just call my old function from the
new one over then I also need to grab
the total count of things in the
document and lastly I'll just return
their quotient and so again you know
looks to God like I'm writing a Python
function to find that and if I didn't
make any mistakes now i'm going to apply
this to my old friend
and I'm going to see that this post is
one point four percent sulphur um which
is to say that one point four percent of
the words that occur in a tower sulfur
and so I remember that was for so this
is like what who's good at math it's not
a big article I'd show of course because
that's why I chose this article but um
go this function and i'll just show you
because um it's kind of nice to see what
this query actually looks like and you
can see my queries are starting to get
long these are starting to be actual
decent size abstract syntax trees um so
the last thing i want to do is I want to
actually use this to as a way to
navigate through my documents and find
documents that might be related to a
certain topic based on the fact that a
high percentage of the words in the
document are that word so thing is I
could write a query like this and order
by is just a way to order by some sort
of a function get everything in orders
that it turns and I could do sent now
this query would return everything in
the order of the percentage of the words
in these documents that are loved if it
ran but it won't run because the data
won't fit in memory and to sort things
they well actually it kind of might on
this but in most real cases your dad
isn't going to fit in memory so you
can't do it like this so um we didn't we
didn't want to implement ordering of
things that don't fit in memory because
that's an easy way to shoot yourself in
the foot and get stuff to be real slow
and when you're really targeting real
time systems that's um sort of more rope
than people necessarily should be given
um but so when you're using a database
and you can't sort stuff in memory what
can you do what's what's the standard
way that you can bat this problem
file sort basic idea sorry what was the
answer down there oh no that's someone
on the phone um the answer I'm looking
for here is an index which is sort of
what file sorting is so give you a
t-shirt small medium large well I'll get
it to you after the talk um so that's
right we create an index and rethink TB
support secondary indexes out of the box
and they're about as pleasant to create
as everything else um I can create one
using the index create command and so
I'm going to call this index love
percent and I pass it a function and
this function is just something that it
applies to every single document and the
value it gets back that's what it
inserts it into the index says now when
I run this function it's going to fail
and you can see in this error message
that it says that the index percent
already exists and the simple reason for
this is just that I already ran this
query ahead of time so that we don't
have to wait for it to complete while
we're here but where I ran it is exactly
the same as the thing i just typed in
promise so now i can use this and now i
have a way to see what are the articles
on Wikipedia that contained the word
love the most and the way that I do this
is I call order by and now rather than
passing in function I can pass in the
name of an index and if I were to run
this query it would give me a bunch of
things that have nothing to do with love
because it's sorting us in ascending
order so we have this kind of funky
syntax to turn things around and sort in
descending order so I'm going to run
this and it's going to crunch for a
second and um go out while this well
this goes any questions yes ah so what
kind of limitations do we have so there
are the limitations that exist basically
because we haven't sort of implemented
the supporting functions for them so leg
off of the top of my head there there's
sort of a lot of library functions that
I've come to expect like Python to have
that it just doesn't that our equal
query language doesn't have um but oh
actually sorry one sec let me get this
to a form that we can actually see
um there there is but I'm not quite sure
if it's it's like underscore something
but I don't it there's definitely a way
to do it um uh yeah so so you definitely
can I just don't know the what it's
called in this rebel um so this is you
be something and actually I'm going to
put a limit on this query so that we
only get 10 results sorry so you're
saying the limitations of what you can
serve really um it's a pretty expressive
query language um things get there are a
few things that Python doesn't really
give you access to so like plus you saw
was very very intuitive because it's
overloaded Python doesn't let you
overload like unary negation it doesn't
let you overload ah boolean inversion so
some of those things you have to stray a
bit off the beaten path but you can
really have quite complex functions
mm-hmm absolutely um you can call you
can call map reduces from within ah
those it's the only thing that you can't
do with in a secondary index is you
can't pass it a non deterministic
function so um and this is for good
reason because the function isn't
evaluated on in a central place like on
the master it's evaluated ah on each
individual replica and if you had a non
deterministic function then different
replicas could wind up with different
impressions of what this secondary index
looked like and then did you get a very
strangely behaving database um but any
language functions can be called within
there as long as they're not like random
number generation and stuff like that
those those we consider nondeterministic
too sorry yes what about network calls
and our pcs you can generally um do so
right now I don't think that we have a
good way for you to actually like call
out into sort of the outside world from
within the database um we have had
proposals to add that in Bay well
however you can't do those get inside of
a secondary index again because yeah if
two people call out into the outside
world we don't know they're going to get
the same thing and if things are
different then everything gets wacky any
other questions yes pletely globally
aware toward per machine from a query
language they have to think about is in
this have to think about oh this this
table is sword sharted across these two
machines mmm it thinks about that in
terms of how it manages the data but um
I just think there's an index on this
table I can access the index using get
methods and stuff and then because I
figured this would would come up i also
created sort of the opposite index which
is the hate percentage um which was
actually unfortunately what i had open
when you guys when i opened up this view
um and so this is going to give me some
less savory articles off of Wikipedia
and then the results are written you can
see their SS unsavory asst one might
have imagined um the so the actually a
lot of texas a surprising amount of
texas in fact on em so the data we store
in a b-tree and um short tons of people
are familiar with be trees but basically
ideas they're like a binary search
tree or any other sort of tree for
storing data except that arm they store
things in blocks so that they're very
very efficient at using various buffer
sizes the whole idea of that is that a
lot of times with a disc it's just as
efficient to read four kilobytes off of
disk as it is to read one kilobyte off
of disk so you might as well get your
money's worth out of that full four
kilobytes but the main things that they
give you from an API perspective is that
they give you the ability to select
things based on the primary key but they
also give you the ability to get ranges
of keys um and that's that's how we do
all of these range operations if you won
so you mean if you do sort of get
something that has a particular value
for something that's not the primary key
so if you want to do that that's going
to be a linear scam unless you create an
index now basically what the index is
it's really exactly the same structure
it's a b-tree and it's actually uses
exactly the same code paths in the
entirety of our product um it's just
that at the very end it's indexing by
these different values very end rather
than store the actual value it stores a
pointer over to the primary be tree so
we only store one copy of the data and
really we've got just all of these be
trees hanging above it pointing down
into this data so that you can access it
in these interesting ways and that's how
getting back our chain ability so I sort
of passed over it without thinking about
it but in in r equal as a language we
have a fairly sophisticated type system
that lets you do variously so as an
example when i take this object on it's
a table and i can see this because i can
actually call a type of method on it
that's a table and
um when I chain in operation so when I
say this dot map actually check that I
can map over um we basically are
implementing you're familiar with
virtual functions in abstract classes
something this is like a virtual method
on that some types have that they can be
mapped over so another example of a type
that I can map over is just an array and
I can create a Python array using expert
and I'll just do one two three four like
this and so I run that I get back one
two three four and then I want to I can
chain map off off of that and um let's
just add one to it and I get two three
four five back um then want to know
about chain ah I see so this guy knows
the answers to the questions of course
um but right to these
it's an array and then when I apply to
it still get back an array and that
means of course if i want to buy another
one maybe this time i'll multiply by 2
and it just go in these these pipelines
these become on very very intuitive once
you work with it for a while the idea of
like okay i get this data at the table
and then I pass it through this
transformation and this transformation
then I bring in this other table and
stuff um it actually becomes a pretty
good way to visualize how the data is
actually flowing around so the the dot
is the question is do we make one trip
to the server but with the dot when you
change things that's just adding stuff
onto the abstract syntax tree and in
fact I should have showed this before
but what does the abstract syntax tree
look like well I've got my array and
then I've got a map and then I've got a
map and just keep going it's all it's
all just one round trip yeah sorry the
question is at what point should you run
the code in um phaser is when you're
worried about that for so I don't know
this sort of a database phrase which is
off to spoken about bringing the query
to the the reason that you do this is
these abstract syntax trees are just you
know a few bites really arm it's like
nothing to transport over the network
whereas your data can be terabytes and
so if your data is small then you might
as well just load it into Python and use
your environment there because you know
this might be like writing Python code
but it's not doesn't have everything
yeah
so people who are using and you just
know my sequel really well i'll give you
my a kind of really the best the
argument is the ability to write these
native functions you know like I've used
sequel and I learned the syntax there
but it's just doesn't feel as expressive
to me as writing these functions that I
already know they're silly serializing
them um that being said actually I'm
going to ask maybe because he does a lot
more marketing and probably has it a
better answer so yeah I think the field
is going to evolve up a bit and people
will spend more time adding features to
all of these products to make them more
viable for analysts that just hasn't
happened yet because the field overall
is young and I think what happens is
whenever you have a use case that's
really really good for no sequel it's
like developers pick the product and in
operations people scale it out and
analysts are sort of left out for now
right so there are data scientists that
right some queries for this that work
but like analysts but it's not quite the
right products for them yet but I think
that will change in the next couple of
years unfortunately that's the best
answer we can give you and I bet every
other no sequel then there will probably
say the same thing ah yes so the
question is do replicas participate in
the computations and the answer is
absolutely um in fact sort of a little
lie here easier to tell us we refer to a
primary and a replica and in terms of
the way that that's implemented we have
the notion of a primary which is just
something that queries go through to get
in a canonical order and then they're
sent out to the replica
and there's absolutely no reason in our
code they you even have to have a
replica any a copy of the data on the
same machine is the primary we just
always do because that's a lot more
intuitive to think about but yeah
there's no such thing as a special
replica really um except for the fact
that replicas could be out of date and
then they don't participate in the query
yeah so so certain types of queries you
know arm yeah I mean basically anything
if you if you want to be able to run
twice as many queries then a lot of
times you can just add a replica you'll
be fine please um so I know of a few
first off the question the question is
who in the community is using rethink TB
um I believe that there are at least a
few companies here who are actually
using rethink to be in production so if
any of them um well if that's true and
anyone wants to speak up we would love
to hear from you arm and other than that
actually I don't know who has said
they're ok with us saying they're using
rethink to be there are hundreds of
production deployments right now and
usually what happens is people don't
necessarily pick it for their core data
set because they're careful I'm you know
about database usage but they pick it
for sort of an auxiliary data sets a one
example of this is analyzing logs like
if you don't want to buy splunk and you
have logs coming in from different
systems you pick everything QB and
people very often just write these
queries ad-hoc to discover things so
sort of like rewriting you know if you
don't want to get splunk or mixpanel or
something like that people use
everything could be for that a lot and
usually it starts out with a use case
like this something auxiliary and then
it starts growing out where people get
comfortable with the language they get
comfortable with the system and at this
point there are quite a few production
deployments of relatively like medium
sized clusters for a real-time system
about six to eight machines with
real-time stuff so it's really
everything from you know building web
applications or mobile applications are
doing simple analytics it's not quite as
good as like duper vertica for that kind
of stuff but if you're doing simple in
the lyrics we think is great real-time
but normally people would go all up so
really it's I mean it's a database right
so it's pretty horizontal and the use
cases are all over the place it's
usually more for real-time things not
analytics type things and that's just
sort of been the case so far and we're
really optimizing for it so i think it's
going to stay stay that way for a while
i actually don't know who the who has
the question so i was just speaking ok
does that make sense ok